we're pleased to have kicking off our
number two right here one of the
funniest guys in the business one of the
best at what he does Thank You the
irresponsible tour of Kevin Hart and
here is Kevin Hart he's like how are you
good man better intro well I could keep
going
I got to talk about there is a ton of
talk to talk about I don't know how much
time you got well I've got to put the
emphasis on my teeth I've got a good
amount of time certainly when you're in
a cold tub with Lavar ball I've got that
to talk about yeah we've got obviously
the Kevin Hart laugh-out-loud radio to
talk about yeah and then oh gosh yes
that's it
Philadelphia Eagles we have got to talk
yeah yes as I'm draped you are Eagles
paraphernalia no that's that's like your
gut so you got the green hoodie
yeah I've went green hoodie and then I
went sad and black Jay I just noticed
the lack even on it this is subtle I
didn't want to come here and be yeah you
know blatant with it this is a subtle
yeah I didn't notice it it's sort of
like a watermark yeah sort of situation
yeah half right that you get up close he
like whoa he really is a Eagles fan
you've got a lot yes got a lot of Eagles
stuff um well we know you're from Philly
yes I am Philly born and bred yes okay
so you were an eagle fan from cradle to
current everything okay everything
Philadelphia all right
who's your favorite Eagle Walter my
favorite Eagle volatile Oh Randall
cutting Hansen you did not stutter then
steady Randall Cunningham he's pretty
popular in this town to you me played
for the Vikings we're talking about my
favorite ego we're gonna keep him in
Philadelphia okay not gonna talk about
him when he started to backslide talk
about the good days as a eagle that's an
eagle
yeah I'll say Randall Cunningham then
I'll say Reggie way Reggie White yeah
yes I'm yes and passion I know Reggie
White Jerome Brown defensive line right
wearing a jersey to the Super Bowl which
is Jerome Brown patch that's what you're
gonna do yes okay Randall Cunningham
Jersey but my jersey has Jerome Brown
patch what will it say on the back let's
say heart bull let's say your nose well
say Cunningham it's a real Jersey okay I
can't make it say heart
I'm no longer thinning if I make a save
heart it's gotta be a real Jersey
understand it's a big moment for me
missed it that's a big game what do you
think what do you mean what I think this
goes will be eighty eighty three to six
I called it I put my prediction I did a
long time ago okay I had a dream I saw
it and how many two thats and how many
touchdowns then for nick foles then
thirty two touchdowns in my head right
now
yeah just I didn't want to show if my
math was good a ballpark
nothing yeah give or take of the awesome
give it take off 1215 maybe they just
did the math in the truck because I'm
more verbal than 224 points so three
times the amount you know assuming they
don't go for two each time you know I
know those are just extra points we're
assuming they're all the extra points I
know I messed up I didn't carry Kevin
Hart here on the Rich Eisen show okay so
we're we're we're I guess does your
allegiance lie I guess in all the
Philadelphia teams you put the Eagles up
there sick where you throw the Sixers
you team's all right well I understand
we're we're a city that's desperate for
something to hold on to you know and and
boast about right now and I think for
the first time in a long time
the the Eagles and the Sixers actually
are conversation pieces you know we're
where we feel good about talking about
both teams yes you know I mean the
Flyers have always had their moments the
Phillies have always had their moments
you know they've been good programs but
the Eagles and a six we've just
struggled you know and that's been tough
so top finally finally have these things
going at the same time right and to talk
about the fact that oh my god the Eagles
are the Superbowl oh my goodness the
Sixers are gonna make the playoffs it's
a different conversation for me now so
right with that being said man you know
I'm I'm much more of a basketball fan
well sure I'm a football fan well we've
seen you play yeah well I'm a four-time
celebrity game MVP
about that I don't want to make it about
my talent
we tan for a second no look just
understand this I chose comedy
basketball chose me you know I could
easily went down that road
listen if basketballs gonna tap you on
your shoulder yeah and just understand I
never turned all the way around
I just gave a glance back right that's
the only reason why I never really
pursued it but I could have played
Division three basketball but you know
sure look it's it's all a choice one on
one you yeah versus Terrell Owens how
does that work oh my goodness you got to
say no backing down if he's not gonna
back me down I beat him but if you
choose to back me down every way so but
off the dribble yeah you gotta go
there's no put you off the dribble yes
you've got him 100% it's not even a
question he has no lateral movement I
played it to her not he's no lateral
movement it's all fast it's all forward
speed him going side to side
he gets clumsy hmm you know he's he's
very heat I think if you asked him he's
just as good as basketball players he's
a football player yeah asking him you
gotta ask somebody that seen him play
he's a good basketball player but you
know I'm not gonna say he's just as good
he's an athlete hmm but what am i you
know whatever you think athlete think
what comes after that that's what I am
I'm I'm something that they don't even
have a word for your - it yes you get it
I get it you get it you're a - but
there's a thing I don't want to be this
guy I just want to tell jokes some days
I get up some days I get up and I'm like
god I don't wanna I don't want to go and
be a runner and run a marathon again
yeah Oh somebody football I caught it
good one hand burden like those things
frustrate me because it's like should I
play professional sports now mm-hmm
or she'll just keep telling jokes I
don't know man it's such a such a thing
you ever meet dr. J yes I do know doc
how about that right I call him a deejay
and he calls ukh cage wrote a nickname
basis is that right yeah we had a good
kind of hold our mentor dr. H well call
me dr. age you know he's kind of he's
got the doctor thing you know I forgot
for you
we both have murals of ourselves
mainland cities late I shake shouts out
do you DJ I mean when when it all comes
down to it who would you say is the the
ultimate Philadelphia athlete that guy
the ultimate is dr. day that's it he's
at the top DJ he's at the top it's dr.
Jay a hundred percent a hundred and ten
percent because it's not just the
athlete you know what it's dr. Jay yes
Allen Iverson is up there
Allen Iverson his way way up there he's
not gonna beat dr. Jay right but he's up
there when it comes to the face of
Philadelphia sure
Allen Iverson was that guy man she was
that guy we embraced him we embrace
Allen Iverson I know well I mean nobody
else everybody that's as close as the
Sixers have come Jim you know that that
one game that they took from Kobe pretty
much is as good as I know and I love
embiid right now all right I just love
watching his game and he but he's got
some comedy chops to do he's that he's
got the makings of a star you know I'm
saying he's he's personable he's great
at his craft and and and he makes the
game appear fun to those that are
watching from afar as a fan yes I love
to see basketball but when I get to see
some trash talk when I get to see some
fun involved when I get to see the guy
interacting with the crowd
good elevating this sport and I mean
that's what MJ did you know that's what
Kobe did LeBron does that you know those
guys that that give fans what they want
plus some he has those qualities man
that thing's gonna be around for a long
time it reminds me a lot of myself when
I played when I played big man this is
an earlier time in my life yes when I
was 13 I played power forward for one of
my basketball teams huh I had a lot of
the same moves that's when you were back
in people down yeah at that time that's
when I you know I've been his height
since I was 13
I shut out the gate here
so I was a big man for quite some time
oh they stopped Rogers when it switched
over Kevin Hart here on the Rich Eisen
show have you met Brady you ever cross
paths with him I've never met him I've
never met him what would you say to him
if you minute I'm a fan I can't I mean
look I joke around as you see him I'm
very yeah silly and I play around a lot
but I'm big on history and greatness so
no matter no matter what you can't deny
that man's greatness in what he is and
what he's done so I would simply be be
and all and say hello man huge fan give
him a nice firm handshake don't say
anything crazy cuz my loyalty lies with
the Eagles some would be disrespectful
but right you have to admire what that
man has done he would have a problem
with your prediction just so you
understand that sounds like his his
situation doesn't follow me that falls
on him man you know what here's here's
what people need to understand about the
Patriots right now and I know there's a
lot of New England Patriots fans there's
a lot of Tom Brady lovers out there as
you should okay they're not running over
the NFL they they didn't breeze through
these playoffs they shouldn't have
beaten the Jaguars they shouldn't have
they did they shouldn't have mm-hmm it's
not like they have displayed this oh my
god they're just nobody's gonna be able
to deal with them is our defense has
been an amazing defense throughout the
whole season I've really see our defense
and our front for getting to Brady if we
get to Brady it's going to be a problem
and we run the ball very well it's gonna
be a grinding game if Foles is going
into this game with so much confidence
after the last game he's got so much
confidence I don't care what you say you
can't beat confidence you know how much
confidence I have you can't beat my
confidence I don't care what you tell me
I'm so confident I'm so confident phos
has confidence our defensive confidence
we are here this is where we said we
will be in the beginning the season and
we got here that's confidence they used
to being here that's cocky that's that's
a little notch in like shoulder shrug
yeah we'll do it again mmm it's not the
same type of confidence it's not the
same type of hunger it's a different
level of hunger and these dogs got to
eat
because it's called as under yeah I know
you know you've got sort of the mix of
cocky and confidence you know like the
hoodie yes which is Bella checks garb
yeah
okay in Eagle hoodie that's cocky yeah
confidence is showing up in that black
jacket
you can't tell can't tell good I mean I
see what you did you're got that's the -
that's your cocky confidence I see what
you did but likable that's thing you
gotta be likeable if you're gonna be
those things if likeable isn't in there
then you can just be called a jerk and
people not like are you saying the
Patriots are not likeable the Patriots
aren't likeable
that's very true I can pay I don't know
why man people hate the pictures if I
hate them they hate the paint I don't
hate the Patriots um
I'm not sitting here like my uh don't
Patriot I don't hate the Patriots I
think that the program has achieved
amazing things I think that man is an
amazing coach and is great at what he
does I will not take that away from I'm
just saying my Eagles this year deserve
to be where we are and it's going to be
a game like it's not something that the
pagers just walking out of there with
it's a game and I really feel like it's
in our favor
that's what I do otherwise you wouldn't
say take the Eagles and give the 76 and
a half points
if you if you if you could have been in
this dream you would believe it - well
speaking of a dream I'd like to take a
break and show the television audience
you and levar ball in ice tubs okay I'm
told that this video has not been
released yet no okay yeah the first I am
honored yes to have here I'm gonna say
this and never thought I would say this
into a microphone
but I'm going to say it Kevin Hart I'm
honored to have the worldwide exclusive
of the premiere of coldest balls
yeah sounded good to the dice the S
sound cocky confident yes man okay you
get it you can't
by the way it's a perfect spot to debut
coldest balls because outside it is
don't television audience dare move
because you're about to see Kevin Hart
and levar ball in separate separate cold
ice tubs yes we'll come back we'll hit
on that a little bit more for the radio
audience do our best to paint that word
picture and then I know you got a big
spot coming up in Los Angeles for the
all-star game as well which I'm excited
about the to talk about that Kevin Hart
in a Eagles hoodie and a black zip-up
Eagles you can't tell it's it's it's
it's kind of a black on black
Eagles logo right settle it's so that's
the confident part how's my posture is
it confident that's [ __ ] well yes it
is I mean you're just like leaning back
relaxed swag yeah you go it's where you
go it's wack
how's my how's my confidence how's my
posture that's all right when we return
from Minneapolis we just saw the world
debut or a clip of it of coldest balls
yes coming soon to your laugh-out-loud
app that's gonna be that's available
right now people go to ios and android
right you go get for free right now man
okay multicultural comedy hood kind of
your interview show right in a way where
you're interviewing a guest but both of
you are in freezing ice-cold tubs yeah I
wanted to put myself in an uncomfortable
situation so I can be as uh as unique
and as funny as I possibly could while
getting the other person to try and be
uncomfortable as well so I had to come
to their world
to show off the guns to well I got guns
I'd ever get this I mean it's another
thing that if they tell if you get
tapped on the shoulder I gotta deal with
it every day I'm like good ah yeah right
oh it's maintenance all that amazing
that stuff understood and your first
guest
Lavar bar bomb okay now well let me say
this first job was getting Lonzo ball
seriously though really I'm being a
hundred percent honest they didn't tell
me my producers and stuff on the show
didn't tell me I thought that I was
going to interview lines or ball that
was on the sheet so they knew all the
long that it was gonna be levar ball
they didn't tell me so he walks in the
room he's like gotcha I'm like what yeah
me you let's talk where's the summit
right now you got to daddy no no this
make people might say Kevin is the issue
with levar is that instead of his son
having the spotlight he's got to get in
that tub with Kevin Hart know what like
I what you think is well here's what I
think first of all after talking to him
I get it
it's it's Joe Jackson effect without
[Laughter]
levar ball without the whooping yeah
it's just he's so passionate about his
kids like he loves those boys and
basketball is his love so he's getting
to see his love reach levels that he
never got to reach through his boys
which ultimately makes him pour more
love and passion into those boys because
he's watching them do what he dreamed to
do so it's really not it's not as bad as
people think it is after you hear and
really understand where it's coming from
like i'ma take them boys and I'ma we're
gonna we won't get a different coach and
I'ma give 24 hours and we all will
practice all day in the backyard like he
it's the it's the mentality of the guide
as I will care what you say because we
won't do it because we can maybe it's he
is living the dream through them and
he's he's excited and passionate about
the clip we just showed is is
laugh-out-loud and again that's going to
be available on February the 8th you're
heading to Los Angeles after this
because you're gonna be doing the
introductions right NBA all-stars and
then your tour the Kevin Hart
irresponsible tour you just added over a
hundred dates 115 dates man domestic and
international this tour will be my
biggest and best you know I feel like my
only competition is myself and I stated
to say I'm constantly trying to beat me
and outdo what I did and I'm put that
pressure on myself so well my last tour
what now I did amazing things and we set
records and with this one I'm trying to
do more that's my passion what was it
like selling out of stadium the home of
the Eagles that home of the Eagles for
you literally the the best feeling that
I've ever had as a comedian was walking
out into that stadium and seeing 50,000
people chair for comedy and literally
there were moments where it was quiet
where people were waiting for the
punchline of the jokes to be able to say
that I played a NFL football stadium in
treated it as if it was a comedy club I
mean that's that's unreal it's it's the
biggest accomplishment to date I love my
city of Philadelphia for supporting me
and coming out and you know what on this
tour the goal was to make the world
laugh which is why I'm traveling all
over you know I mean right now it's
conversations of me going to Thailand
going to India to my show
so close it's definitely picked up man I
can't wait get you tickets down there
Lodge Nation Live Nation entertainment
comic it's an information before I let
you go we have a game that we play here
called start bench cut okay sort of like
the you know what marry kill game okay
where you get clean we try yeah well
start bench well we make the good of
that you know the marry part is the
bench parquet okay so we give you three
here we go all right start bench caught
here with Kevin Hart here are your three
choices to play basketball at have as a
teammate okay the rock cube will Will
Farrell
you have to start one of them all right
well I match one or you've been in
movies with all of these guys yeah I
have i'ma start Will Ferrell you start
well yeah Jackie moon gets to start
Jackie moon gets to start just because
I've know that he's got the passion
behind a game okay
his spirit is always high i'ma cut the
rock I'm a cutting Wow
why is attitude oh is that dude I don't
like that - and you're gonna bench cube
you're gonna bring cube off the bench
cube off the bench
I'm bringing cube off the bench because
cube cube is too cool to play the whole
game so there's gonna be no mr. cube
look at his sneaks anyway I just
realized I'm messin easy you ain't cute
you can sit down for a second and get
your new pair of sneaks you gotta keep
you you gotta keep him calm you know you
don't want to give you yeah yeah yeah
like this getting upset I'm gonna make
sure that tomorrow's gonna be sunglasses
on it's oh yeah and [ __ ] it's a smart
move here with wills the tallest of them
all like inside out game with you yeah
man Wolf Man will go down me I got to
start will but the rocks out of here
okay Kevin Hart for real on Twitter Live
Nation entertainment calm for tickets
and information about the Kevin Hart
irresponsible tour check out again
coldest balls on February the 8th I love
saying that man I love having the
ability to be able to get away sing that
into a microphone on the laugh out loud
comedy Network or laugh out loud calm at
youtube.com slash lol network as well
for launching Kevin Hart what the fit
and straight from the heart will debut
also on February 14th on Kevin Hart's
laugh-out-loud radio on Sirius XM and I
think I hit on all that including the
8080 3 to 6 final score for your Eagles
83 to 6
go fly eagles fly there you go that's
Kevin Hart on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience